- Yep--
- Oh my god!
(Brooklynn screams)
- Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, I can't do
that; no, no, no, thank you.
(upbeat music)
- Hi everyone, my name is Devin,
and today we're playing What's in the Box:
The Horror Edition
with the cast of "The Turning."
So if you've ever wondered what it's like
to be a nanny working in a haunted house,
you should check out "The Turning."
(screams)
(dramatic music)
(panting)
- Bad dreams?
- "The Turning" was so scary-
(soft haunting music)
(loud gasp)
(scream)
Make sure that you empty your bladder
before you see this bad boy.
- I play Flora.
There's a lot of mystery to her.
- [Kate Character] What
happened to your last nanny?
- Like I'd tell.
- I play Miles. He's
kind of a dick (laughs).
(laughter)
(dramatic music)
I know what you're afraid of.
He's just like constantly
has a wrestling match
going on in his head.
You shouldn't be in here.
(loud startling gasp)
(glass shatters loudly)
- I play Kate.
This is my first live-in job.
And I come into the house
that these kids live in.
Hello.
(dramatic music)
(screams)
- You're lucky we didn't
put a snake in your boots.
- You're lucky I don't
(upbeat music)
- This is our mystery box.
And you're gonna slide your hand
right down all the way in there,
and whoever can guess what's in the box
and what they're feeling wins.
- I'm like, teeth-chattering nervous.
But--
(faint air blowing)
(soft music)
- [Devin] So this is our first time.
- [Finn] Okay.
- [Mackenzie] Oh my god.
- [Devin] Finn do you wanna try it?
(screams)
- [Mackenzie] I'll do it.
I'll do it with you, come on.
- Oh.
(laughing)
Straight up, a bug.
- Let's reveal what's in the box.
- [Finn] It's like--
(shouting)
- Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, what's that big thing?
- [Devin] Do you know
this is actually a baby?
It's a baby cockroach.
- Oh my god, that's an
insane thing to put in there.
(soft music)
- [Devin] All right,
let's turn around and see
what's in this box.
- I feel like this is such an act of faith
after what you just did.
- I'm the littlest.
- [Mackenzie] What did you do?
Oh I am so scared.
I am so sorry--
- All right, Finn show 'em how it's done.
- I'm still rattled by
the cockroach thing.
(laughing)
- All right, guys.
Oh my gosh.
(screams)
(laughing)
- [Finn] It's a person.
- [Brooklynn] Oh my gosh.
- This is such a good game.
(laughing)
- I've never seen you like this before.
(upbeat music)
- [Devin] Let's see, what's in this box?
Who wants to put their hand in first?
- You do it.
- One safe space.
- [Finn] Then do it.
- [Mackenzie] What's in it?
- It's very cold.
- [Mackenzie] Describe to the audience.
- [Finn] Is it like chicken
or some chicken breast.
(laughing)
- Follow-up question: Do you think you
put this in your mouth?
- Ick, don't ever.
It's probably...
Oh, it's fish.
- It's fish.
Let's see what's in this box.
- Oh.
Aw, that's gross.
- It's dinner.
- [Finn] Hi, buddy.
(dramatic music)
- Miles.
- Nothing should have to suffer.
- So thank you, guys, so much for playing
What's in the Mystery Box.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for having us.
- You are so brave.
Finn, you are the winner.
So you can tell everyone you know.
- Finn was the most brave.
- [Devin] Make sure you see "The Turning"
in theaters January 24.
- [Brooklynn] Woo hoo!
- Sorry if I scared you.
(screams)